but Trinity to me is
illogical does it make sense yeah but
makes sense to you yes basically God is
one and one in existence and if you read
cam cosmological
argument it makes sense in that he's one
what he's one in
existence what do you mean one in exist
one entity one Divinity one one I
believe the same thing so what's what's
the problem with the
Trinity because when you say there are
three persons you're creating this you
know idea that God has to be in three
ways or there's no other way and it
logically doesn't make sense I I think
that it's logically necessary for him to
be multi-personality
he's one so he creates things if he's
already three he wouldn't need to create
anything he can just indulge it you're
right he doesn't need to so I got you so
you're saying since Allah is only one
yeah then that means he needs to create
well in yeah according to his um
otherwise he would not why would he
create something if he doesn't need or
wants are you a Sunni
Muslim uh I mean I am Sunni Muslim yes
but if you're going to bring up Hadith I
don't follow all of them no no I'm not
I'm not going to bring up Hadith I just
want want to make sure I
got I just want to make sure I I got
you so
uh okay this is the
27th I'm I'm I've just been um like
marking
down the different things that Muslims
been saying to me this year that I've
heard that has been yeah you know
just yeah it's it's our our
understanding God did not
his yeah I got you intentions per se
Allah
Allah because he's
one
needed uh to
create I mean need need word might not
be appropriate here that was a slip of a
tongue would say wanted to it was oh I
mean I I don't think that it was a slip
of a tongue at all I think that I think
that you're actually accurate if Allah
is one
person he would need to
create you're right I can show you why
you're right you want to see well I
would say he would not create otherwise
I would say this if he I mean we don't
understand God's nature but if you just
think as human being because they say
you know that human being have
somewhat according to Christianity you
say God's like
um let's progress it this way in the
Quran a lot of times you see Allah speak
in the plural of them speak of himself
in the plural he says we and our and us
a lot right why is that well that's
really known fact is a royal wi and
that's a you know known fact it's not
really a royal wi what what is the Royal
we what is that it's when somebody is
signifying his might it's like a king
would you know like you know you don't
talk like you know no you're right he's
the he's signifying his might yeah right
so you're saying it's it's mighty it's
it's mighty to uh appear as plural right
it's more Mighty to appear as a
plurality is that correct yeah yeah for
I mean you can just say that if if
they're like 10 people people versus one
person who's who's going to have more
power man that's interesting so Allah in
order to appear more Mighty than he
really is he refers to him in the plural
to signify his his mightiness because
it's more Mighty to be plural rather
than
singular it's it's just a it's it's a a
literal device to you know yeah to
signify his majesty right yes yes it's a
literal device to signify his majesty
yes so it's more Majestic to be plural
rather than singular right wouldn't say
that like for example a king would say
we are you know coming something like
this it doesn't mean he's trying to say
that you know it displays his majesty
it's yeah it the plurality displays more
Majesty than Singularity does being
plural signifies more Majesty than being
absolutely singular is that right
in in a in a literal you know like in a
what do you call it in a speech you
could say yes so this is my thing in
Islam when it comes to
Ted your God has to pretend to be more
Majestic than he is not pretend no this
is a wrong no it is I I know but I I
have to be I have to be blunt with it so
forgive me I I'm just being a little
blunt um but but he has to act or appear
as more Majestic than he is while the
trun God just
is in his own nature he's
plural he doesn't have to when when he's
when he there has doesn't have to be a
royal we it doesn't have to uh s do
something to signify his his majesty
because he already is plural okay he so
even if we Le let's take for um just for
the sake of argument let's say there are
three you know Persons Of God let's say
there's father a son and a holy spirit
let's say that right if individual like
let's say father is speaking in this way
he would also call himself V even though
he might be talking about himself like
Father sent his son do we send our son
in you know if you're talking in a Royal
sense that's how that's how the language
is that's what I'm trying to tell you no
it's not and he never says that no
that's not how it works well in Old
Testament it say Elohim right
right does it or doesn't it what do do
you get what I said well I'm I'm I'm
trying to see you you're saying that
he's trying to make it into a multiple
person you you said this is what I need
you to pay attention to what you said
you
said that it is more
Majestic to be plural rather than
singular that's what you said this is
what the plural Majesty in a language
yes yeah in a language different right
but this is what your God is
demonstrating himself to be he's coming
off as if he's plural to signify his
majesty but he's not plural so he's not
really as Majestic as he's coming
off to be if he's plural then he truly
is that Majestic like Yahweh is like the
TR the Trinity the Trinity Tri the
Triune God doesn't have to to come off
as Majestic he is that Majestic that
plural of majesty he doesn't have to
pretend to be that he doesn't have to
appear that way so let's say father is
the father is Alone by himself is he
Majestic or Not by himself the father
that's impossible that's that's like
saying uh Allah without his knowledge
you see how like nonsensical that is the
father is be separated the father cannot
be separated from the Son and the spirit
bro there is there is no father by
himself Spirit by himself
but let's let's go to the next phase of
showing you why what you said earlier
right that because Allah is only one
person not just one entity just like one
person that he needed to create let me
show you
why um let me ask you
this needed was of a tongue it was he
wanted to create he he willed to create
because he was I know I know I I know
you're saying you're rejecting it which
is okay you can reject that however
I'm holding on to it because I'm going
to show you that what you said although
may have been a slip of the tongue on
your part but actually was correct
matter of fact I don't even think that
it was you that said that by yourself I
believe that it wasn't flesh and blood
that revealed to you that if Allah was
only one person he would need creation I
think it was my Father in Heaven who
revealed to you that if Allah was only
one person he would need creation I'm
going to show you why I'm going to show
you how but before we go if if I ask you
question about the word father will you
be able to answer after this we will you
know or is it just about depends on how
much time I have if I have enough time
then we can if not um your name is Aslam
Khan come come on uh Wednesday and we
can continue okay I I'll you'll be
priority if you come up come on time
I'll make sure you're priority all right
okay so would you say that that Allah is
loving yes definitely the most loving
the most loving yeah got no love
compares to his well even according to
had a mother's love is even way less
than you know God's love nice okay I got
you I got you okay all right let me ask
you this then since God's love is
greater than anyone else's love yes all
right I got you and it's greater than
even a mother's love yes let ask you
this is it a greater love which which
form of love is greater if you just love
yourself which is okay you know you can
love yourself take care of yourself
right um if you love yourself or if you
share your love with another which form
of love is greater that selfish love or
just shared love sharing love yeah okay
all right so sharing love is greater
than let's say a selfish love where you
just love yourself only got it okay now
to have a shared love that requires
at least two parties
right yeah in a human way I I I know
where you're going but okay it's not
even in a human way it's just period
shared love requires two parties in
order to have shared love right one
gives their love to another and vice
versa that's shared love that form of
love is greater than singular than
selfish love all right so the greater
form of love since God's love is greater
than anyone's yeah then God at least at
the very least has to have within his
own Essence shared
love without depending on anyone
else before time we don't
really that's that's something that I
don't know I I comprehend that you can
comprehend it for example you believe
Allah is only one person right before
there was any creation before there was
any Angel any gy in a human being right
yeah I see where you're going I'm just
saying I I can't comprehend that I don't
know if he was loving himself or
something else or loving the concept of
creation that's the only thing he could
do the only thing he could do is love
himself now let's say he's loving the
concept of creation right let's say he
has he has Creation in his mind and so
in his mind he loves creation so still
then but that's not a shared love
because one that creation is not in
existence yet to share for him to
actually give that love to creation and
for creation to also re uh you know uh
give that love back to God right so that
that's not there it's only a potential
there it's potential but it's not
reality yet you get what I'm saying yeah
so and love is not just like just a
concept it's reality right it's you know
what you do for others right so for God
to you know be God right yeah is the
greatest love his love at the very least
there's it's higher but at the very
least he at least has to have shared
love within his own Essence without
depending on
creation yeah however Allah can't right
because Allah can only love himself or
because Allah is only one person he
would need
Creation in order to have a greater form
of
love physical yes but if you say he
loves the concept you know that's
different so this is I'm I'm just
showing you my brother that you were
right and it it was my Father in Heaven
who revealed this to you it wasn't
yourself it wasn't flesh and blood if
Allah's only one person then he is
dependent on creation he needs creation
because he can't have shared love
without it well you can say the love
started after the creation was before
before that he was was you know the love
started the love started after creation
right I could I mean logically it would
make sense yeah yeah so his shared love
begins once creation is created right
yeah so Allah is dependent on creation
to have shared love he can't have shared
love within his own self yeah but see
according to Islam before human beings
were created they were um angels and
they were Gins you know and I'm talking
about before that angels and Gins are
part of creation do you agree yes yes
they they were created now I don't know
when they were were they I know I know I
I know you don't know when it doesn't
matter but just talking about they are
part of creation yeah right so what I'm
saying is creation period not just human
beings I see I see what you're saying I
just I don't know I don't know the
answer it's something there is no answer
brother there is no answer it's it's
it's it's very simple Allah in order to
have a greater form of love than shared
love I me I'm sorry than selfish love he
is dependent on
creation he cannot have a greater form
of love by hisself he can't do it okay I
mean something to think about so can I
ask my question if you have time wait
wait let me let me tie a knot let me tie
a knot okay I'm showing you the contrast
so if Allah is one person then he's not
self-sufficient he's insufficient and
dependent on creation if God is triumph
soon then he doesn't need creation to
have shared love why would he create
that well he doesn't need to but the but
his creating is out of love even for his
own creation for him to create us for
him to create me let me just say it like
this for God to even think of me and to
bring me into reality to experience his
goodness and his grace his mercy and his
loving kindness his his uh unmar favor
his character it's such a benefit to
it's not a benefit to him I appreciate
that thank you for bringing me into
existence to experience you God that's
my attitude so so God needs to be
Trinity to in order so he still he needs
he needs to be Trinity to you know love
himself well well notice him needing to
be Tri Triune is not him needing
anything outside of himself he's relying
on it's his own
you get what I'm saying that's almost
like saying God needs to be God needs to
have knowledge in order to be all
knowledgeable I'm trying to say I'm
trying to say trinity is God you know
you see it's the one God right so it
still is it isn't it like selflove if TR
Trinity is one God you know because
that's what you the reason why the
reason why it's not just selfish love
but it's shared love and Cooperative
love is because there's multiple person
persons within the essence of God that
is fellowshipping together and communing
together coexisting together and giving
that love and sharing that love with
each other and reciprocating that love
to the same level that's how that's done
in the trinity in the Trinity the
Trinity is love that's why our Bible
says God not just is loving not just has
love the Bible says that God is love in
his very
nature so at the very core at God's very
in his Essence there is a communion and
a fellowship of love between the father
Son and Holy
Spirit you don't have that with Allah so
the Triune God the god of the Bible
doesn't depend on anything outside of
himself to have a greater form of love
than humans but Allah does he's
dependent
all right well something to think about
I will you know ask questions to my
Muslim friends all right look hold the
so you you wanted to ask about the
father I promise you because I do have
to go because we're I usually stop at
three hours but I stayed enough for you
okay but come Wednesday I'm live I don't
know what your what what your time frame
is but I'm live um at 5:00 P PM Eastern
Standard Time Wednesday okay come back
Wednesday and you can ask you wanted to
ask about the father or something right
so remember that question Maybe write it
down and come bring it I remember okay
good yeah good bring it Wednesday okay
okay see you all right take care God
bless all right with that being said
guys I love you all I hope that you guys
learned I hope you guys were blessed um
shout out to Bella who gave her
testimony here she is a Muslim who
converted from watching our videos and
also come across Sam's videos and Chris
Christian Prince or David Wood's videos
and um and she's just eager and excited
to get baptized so let's pray for her
that God leads her and guide her guides
her on on this
journey let me get to some of these
super chats that I missed before we
close
out I see a large one in here hold on
who who who dropped the C
note hey Raul Perez thank you so much
for your generosity thank you so much my
friend God bless you God bless
you oh ancient of day debate is over I
don't I don't remember what context that
was in let me see here get Caleb on the
panel please uh Caleb can come next time
if he's here I don't know if
he's I see the Hebrew name okay Kayla my
bad bro um come come um come on
Wednesday come on
Wednesday let's see here AA rapid Hall
says hey bro been watching for a while
now I've been wondering if you heard of
World Mission Society Church yeah they
believe in Christ
unsung yeah uh World Mission Society
they
believe in some weird stuff uh I believe
that's also the group that believes in
God the mother they believe in God the
mother and it's very rare that you'll
find them but you'll come across them um
and they're very aggressive to like
they're they're very they're pushy and I
just wish that I would run into them I
ran into to them before few years back
in my college days and uh they hated me
they hated me but um I never I never get
to run into them again Lord please put
them in my path again so
yes let's see Manny it just comes
natural to the Triune God glory to God
Amen to that bro
exactly we got Jason Casper in the house
he says look Allah can't love himself
I promise you
Jason
Manny and uh there's there's a few
others of you guys that I'm missing
y'all are the funniest people that be in
the chat y'all really be cracking me up
and I think you guys like make it a goal
to make me crack while I'm live goodness
I be trying to stay professional
sometimes y all just come out of the
Wheelworks with some random stuff oh but
he needs a mate for that that's right
Jay thank you so much knowledge
knowledge equals
God where um can I send
merch yeah guys the the the merch is is
actually coming soon if you guys saw the
post we got some shirts that are uh that
are underway just finding a manufacturer
and we'll be all set and ready to uh
roll them out so I think the first thing
that's going to be coming out is we just
read we just we're gonna be coming out
with some we just read
shirts all right so stay tuned for
that logic did you see my email I have
my username as the subject love you bro
I did not I get way too many emails
Let's see we got Kirby Pooh says amazing
how the Holy Spirit uses Avery and the
plus the English plus English language
usage plus a few repetitions
to make it all click amen I know what
he's talking about
there all right with that being said I
think that's it that I'm going to read
so far let's see here you're using SLC
confusing God's Elohim with divinity the
ancient of God L the father made a
Lesser God aka the son 1 Corinthians
8:6 the the father made a
lesser I don't know if that's your view
or if he's talking to me or was he
talking to a guest but definitely there
is no Lesser God that's been made at all
in any way she form the son is the most
high and if anybody disagrees with that
y'all can come over here and challenge
me on Wednesday again Isaiah 63 holy
holy holy is the Lord Almighty the whole
earth is full of his glory three times
holy is said amen